hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice nimso game app from the Gaza
hiteni Memorial Tournament it is a
petrol hashka versus a pregnant and it's
a game from round six Prague was doing
excellently in the tournament he had
four victories in a row and then he lost
in round five to I'm in tabatabai uh now
we're checking up on what's happening in
game six like I said a really really
awesome active names of Indian game and
as it's a very popular opening I'm sure
a lot of you guys are enjoying it uh
let's check it out so uh pet has the
white pieces and he opens with Pawn to
D4 uh sorry about that
uh we have Knight to F6 and the pretty
standard stuff C6 C4 E6 Knight to C3 and
now Bishop to B4 going for the names of
Indian defense with Ponte E3 then the
standard line or the normal line or uh
the traditional line I I never really
know what's the queen to see to is the
classical and the E3 sort of the
traditional line that's what they call
them uh but okay here we have castles
and now uh three moves are very very
popular here Bishop to D3 Knight to F3
and Knight um uh G to E2 but here we
have Bishop to D2 this is the fourth
most popular move and this is what um I
better prepared for pregnant as well he
is definitely expecting that Prague is
very well versed in all of the lines
maybe this one he knows uh a little bit
less and it has been played by some
extremely strong players Fabiano caruana
played the ding play that Wesley so
played it though it is a feature played
it so it's definitely a playable move uh
in every time format we have pawned the
five by Prague Knight F3 B6 and now C
captures on D5 we have e captures and
Bishop to D3 the bishop uh often placed
on D3 against the denim so we have Bush
back to D6 and now castles we have Rook
to E8 Knight to B5 now putting pressure
on the dip on the bishop and for the
moment Bishop back to f8 uh it again
looks maybe a bit weird on f8 but um
it's going to be a great defender and
once you kick away the Knight then you
can easily bring it back into the game
so Knights the E5 and now Bishop to A6
sporting pressure on the Knight here and
now Bishop to E1 uh so the bishop and D3
sorry division D3 is defended if you
move your knight and there is a game
where C5 was played
is played against Harsha baratakoti uh
this year some three three months ago
but here we have Pawn to C6 by Prague
and it is now as of move 12 that we have
a completely new game so okay Knight
back to C3 uh Bishop captures on D3 proc
trades of the light Square Bishops and
here uh Queen to C8 and this is uh okay
you are adding another Defender to C6
you are adding another Defender to the
A6 Square so now you can develop the
Knight here and this is uh often I don't
know if you guys have tried playing the
ninja the the C pawn and the A6 Square
will usually be what um it is the most
problematic when trying to create some
sort of a solid setup so okay Rook the
C1 now again you have to be careful you
don't want to run into Knight captures
on D5 or Knight to B5 or while your
queen is here for the moment the Knight
is on F6 so it's okay but you have to be
careful so Queen to B7 and now Pawn to
F4 uh we have Knight B to D7 finally the
Knight can be safely developed and now
Bishop to H4 uh Rook 8 the C8 by prog
and feather goes for Pawn to A3 with
Ponte 5 stopping B4 and now Pawn to G4
going all out here on the king Side Pawn
to C5 and now Bishop captures an F6 uh
we have Knight captures and now Pawn to
G5 just grabbing more space here Knight
to E4 and now what do you play here
uh well from experience you probably
know that when that light lands on e4 uh
you can capture but it's usually black
that will uh profit from this even if uh
even if you double black spawns and
black has a double e Pawn uh it's still
going to be okay for black so it's not
maybe something to look forward to so
instead Petra tries and D captures on C5
and now Knight captures on C3 and now
not what you'd expect not real
characters followed by big captures on
C5 because even this is fine for black
black has very nice control over the uh
Center here and on the queen side and
okay white does have this expansion on
the king side but his King is also quite
loose so black is the one to be
preferred here so instead he plays Pawn
to C6 and this is where things get a
very interesting progress says all right
I don't mind Rook captures on C6 he
gives up the exchange Knight captures
and now what was prague's idea here for
this position it's not easy to spot it
but when you see it you will not be able
to unsee it so feel free to pause the
video and try to find the only way for
Prague to look for advantage while I
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on finding not the
winning move but the strongest way to
continue the game which is often even
harder and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Rook
captures on C3 yeah not Queen captures
on C6 if you just trade Queen captures
then Road captures on C3 attacks the
queen and okay if Bishop to C5 yes you
put pressure on E3 but the queen will
just move and not much has been gained
here however after this Rook captures an
E3 move now it's very hard to decide on
how to go about this if you just want to
pretend like nothing happened okay you
play Queen to D2 you just move the queen
from Harm's Way Bishop to C5 now
threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries once The Rook moves we have
to play King to H1 Queen will capture on
C6 Pawn captures on C3 and uh black will
always be much better here yes white is
up the exchange but this bishop is an
absolute monster the queen is a monster
The Rook is beautifully placed here
there's no way to attack for white
um I mean it's just better are from
black so instead Petra went for Queen
captures on E3 he said all right I'm
giving up the queen but I will have the
two Rooks so okay Bishop to C5 this is
what you had to find when you found that
Rook captures an E3 move Rook captures
on C3 with Bishop captures and E3 with
check Rook captures and queen captures
and C6 and now if you look at the
position okay Prague is up a queen uh
yeah Peter is up two Rooks and Prague is
up a pawn so one thing that definitely
goes in prox favor is the uh that the
white king is so loose so can he do
something about this with perfect play
it's probably a draw but as always with
perfect play Everything is a draw Rook
to D1 uh we have Queen to C5 now not
allowing The Rook to move King to F2
defending the rook and pawn to H6 now
trying to mess up the pawn structure in
front of the white king even further
Rook to D2 and now Queen to C4 uh
putting pressure on the F4 Pawn you have
to look for these uh little
opportunities again at least some
Advantage Rook to F3 and now Pawn to H5
not going for the trade but now Pawn to
G6 and this is probably
uh trying to trying to get too much out
of the position you should just you know
be patient play some liking to G2 play
B3 uh and uh wait for proc to come at
you but he decided to go uh forward he
played Pawn to G6 and okay F characters
and G6 and now King to G2 only now we
have Queen to E4 again uh pinning The
Rook uh and now King back to F2 we have
King to F7 bringing the king into the
game Rook after D3 now trying to win the
pawn here uh so here we have Queen to H1
of course none of you were considering
Rook a queen captures on F4 because then
Rook F3 just uh picks up the queen so I
have to Rook after D3 Queen back to H1
and now we have Rook captures on D5 uh
giving up the H2 Pawn but it's not much
better okay you could play maybe play
yeah King to G3 uh but the better
decided against it he played Rook
captures on D5 Queen captures an H2 and
now King to F3 with Queen H3 checking F2
and queen to H4 with check King to G2
and now Queen to G4 with check with King
to F1 and now Queen to F3 with check
King to G1 uh sorry about that
uh King to G1 and now King to G8 we have
Rook 5 to D4 adding a Defender to the
pawn Here and Now Queen to G3 check so
uh proc has a good position but is it
enough to actually grab the full point
well King to F1 we have quanta H4 if
anything he does have the past H Pawn uh
Rook D to Rook 2 to D3 attacks the queen
queen G4 and now Rook to d8 with check
we have King to H7 and now Prague is
completely winning unless uh Petra finds
the only counter play left in the
position and he does he plays Rook to f8
uh not just defending the pawn here but
also threatening Rook to the Eightfold
by Rook to h8 Checkmate and it's not
easy
uh figuring out how to continue this I
might even try to get you to pause the
video here once more but this time try
to actually find the winning move while
I give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it uh congratulations on not going for
the obvious uh Ponte H3 and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is of course Pawn to G5 you have to free
up this Square for the king and to give
you a reason why to do this uh if you
play Pawn to H3 then Rook the d8
threatens Checkmate and yes you can play
Pawn to G5 now but now F5 just takes
away the G6 Square from the black king
and now how are you defending uh Rook to
h a Checkmate uh there's no way to do it
you're forced to just continually uh
check the uh check the white king and
until uh well uh you get uh either a
threefold repetition or a 50 move rule
but basically you will probably agree to
a draw much much sooner than that let's
say working A2 Queen to C4 with check
and then we just repeat the whole thing
so that's why it would not be best
Advanced upon right away so Pawn to G5
again congratulations that this is uh
what you found and also what proc played
uh and now F5 is not as potent uh if F5
now then just Queen to C4 and how are
you getting out of this now uh there's a
problem because the Rook is pinned you
cannot play Rook to d8 and also once you
defend the Rook H3 not only that you
cannot play Rook today you also can't
capture an H3 so now black is completely
winning so after G5 F captures and G5
was played but now Queen captures on G5
we have Rook to F2
uh and now Queen to B5 uh trying to pick
up the Rook here Rook the D2 defending
and now Pawn to G5 and now it's a bit
different uh with the F Pawn gone and
now the two connected pass pawns will be
incredibly difficult to uh to try and
stop King G2 we have King to G6 Rook the
D6 with Chair King to H5 and Rook 6 the
D5 attacks the queen here Queen to C6
again uh not allowing The Rook to move
so King H2 and now Queen to C4 we have
Rook 5 to D4 and now Queen to F1 we have
rooked the d8 trying to get some uh
action behind the black king but now
Queen to F for check King to H1 and pawn
to H3 now the king will be if if Rook to
J then the king will be safe uh that you
don't really have to worry even King to
G4 will be an option so here King to G1
was played but now Queen to E5 not even
allowing a single check here we have
Rook 8 to D7 trying to get a check on H7
but Prague doesn't even allow this queen
to E4 now guard H7 and also if this Rook
moves you will get checkmated on G2 so
King to H2 we have G4 here Rook 7 to D5
with check and now King the H4 we have
Rook 5 to D3 now trying to keep an eye
on the G3 square but it doesn't work
Queen T5 checking to G1 and queen to E5
check and it was in this position on 62
that Peter prohaska resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here so
very nicely done by Prague out of six
games taking his fifth win uh with with
some very impressive play and okay he
was challenged his name is always
challenged with that for Bishop a d2
move on the fourth move which isn't that
often played but uh as usual he just
shows that he knows what's what and that
it's not a problem for him so here we
resign it's actually a forced check made
in four let's say King to H2 move now
comes G3 with check only moves to
capture then you capture this Rook with
check and once you move the king now
comes King captures on G3 with any
checks being made on the next move okay
white will have uh well at least
something he can play B4 before the rest
of the game but now Queen C1 is
Checkmate Queen D1 is Checkmate Queen E1
is Checkmate this check me this check
metal and anything you place Checkmate
here uh so yeah very nice
I hope you guys enjoyed this beautiful
showing on how to
Indian uh We've like I said we've had
many uh many games where uh sorry uh
we're Knight to F3 was played they were
Bishop to D3 was played were a nice uh
uh G2 E2 was played uh Bishop to D2 not
so often but now you've also seen how to
treat that if you're a nimzo Indian
player uh so yeah I really hope you guys
enjoyed it very nicely done by Prague I
would like to thank David Kimura Rod
Hill Phil maltus John and uh Johan
Bridger and Richard Phillips for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos
Sarah thank all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the Chess World so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day